-Here's how
the game works, Brian,
you're going to start the roun
by pressing start on this buzzer
and then drawing a clue
from the top of the pile.
You have to get your partner
to guess the clues
as quickly as possible.
Then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right.
You can make any physical
gesture, say whatever you want
But you can't say any word
in the actual clue.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round
We're going to play
three rounds.
Let's take our positions.
All right, Brian, you're there
Shailene, you're across from me.
-After you.
-Good luck, Tariq.
-Oh, boy.
-You're just a little
too confident today.
-Not going to need a hand.
This feels eerily really
important right now.
-You're sweating for no reason
-It really does.
I don't know why my hands
are on the table.
-It's not even
part of the rules.
Brian, when you're ready -
-Oh, boy.
-You will press the buzzer
and then press start.
-And we take one clue at a time.
Once we get the clue,
we pass the buzzer.
-Yeah, one clue at a time.
Partner, let's go.
-Just breathe.
Okay, ready? Okay.
-You can use words.
-Oh, right.
[ Laughter ]
-Spiderman.
-Yeah, there you go.
-My turn.
Okay, so, it's an instrument
that you hit like this?
-Drums. Drumstick.
-And instead of
being with people, when you're
by yourself.
Han --
-Solo.
-Yes.
-Drum solo.
-Oh, eh?
-Nice.
-It's a type of dog,
a real little one.
-Chihuahua.
-A little bigger.
-Pomeranian.
-This could go on all night.
-Starts with that letter.
Starts with a P.
-Pit bull.
-Not a pit bull,
not a Pomeranian.
Fluffy.
-A poodle?
-Yes.
-Oh, God.
-Whoa.
-Cool. Relaxed. Slow motion.
Slow motion fall.
-John Wayne.
-I told you I can't do people.
[ Buzzer ]
I told you I can't do people
-Keanu Reeves.
-"Matrix." I was doing --
-I was wondering what
that one was. I was like -
-Come on. Alright, fine.
Alright, good.
-Sorry, man.
-No pressure.
-Gosh, how many dogs
are you going to name?
-I'm just saying --
[ Laughter ]
-I think I named every dog
except poodle.
-Whatever.
-We're still in it. Okay.
If it's a person,
just skip to the next.
-Got you, no problem.
-Wow, this sounds like cheating.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready? This fun.
It's all about fun. We're having
a good time. Here we go.
[ Buzzer ]
Okay, uh, it's a summertime.
The ocean.
-Vacation?
-Sand.
-Beach?
-Okay, but if you're not
wearing clothes.
-It's a nude beach.
-There you go.
-Okay.
Okay, it's when you go to thos
really crazy cowboy places
and you do this thing.
-Mechanical bull.
-Yes.
-Okay, this is when
you're in college
and you want to get vodka
down your throat really quick.
You freeze it. And then you --
-You put it in your eyes?
-Yeah, but what is that?
[ Laughter ]
It's gelatinous --
-Jello shots!
-It's a dance.
It rhymes with Fandango.
A dance!
-The tango?
-Yes.
[ Buzzer ]
-How does it count?
[ Laughter ]
-Rhymes with Fandango?
-We got it.
-I'm not even going to
ask the judges.
I'll give you that round,
right there.
There they are,
the champs right there,
Brian Tyree Henry
and Tariq Trotter.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why even compete against that?
Our thanks to Shailene Woodley
Brian Tyree Henry.
Tariq Trotter.
Rhymes with Fandango.
[ Cheers and applause ]